- Nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you, too.
- Have you met before?
- [Both] No.
- But we both love "Real Housewives."
- Oh, love.
- So we're gonna do
a whole deep dive later,
I'm certain of it.
- Okay, okay, you're both into that.
- For sure.
- This is unfortunately
one of those moments
where you're meeting your
absolute biggest fan.
And I'm gonna be sort of, like,
(Kelly laughs)
when you were with Meryl
on the Golden Globes.
- Oh, my God.
- I hope that doesn't make
you nervous, but I have stats.
I have seen you in concert 13 times.
- What?
(audience gasps)
- [Chloe] Wow.
- 13.
- What? I love you.
- I didn't know this.
- You don't know, this is-
- I knew a little, 'cause
I have a video I wanna show
that I thought was amazing.
- Well, yeah, I've done my research.
Honestly, like, it goes all the way back.
Like, I think it was obviously 2002,
you were on "American
Idol" as we all know.
And truly-
- I don't know if everyone knows that.
- Well, I don't know.
All of America knows their idol, I think.
(Kelly laughs)
If they don't, come on, people.
- [Kelly] There's a bunch of us.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's true, what is it, like 16? 17?
- [Kelly] There's a lot of us now.
- You might be the most
memorable. No shade.
- I'll just, you know, I'll just take it.
I'll picture it that way.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Matt] Applause.
(audience cheers)